qu'est ce que le marché gris il ya un
bon exemple dans un article la presse
aujourd'hui l'entreprise coty a
découvert que ses parfums en qu'en
théorie elle était la seule à pouvoir
vendre au canada étaient aussi offerts
chez cosco à une fraction du prix
c'est pour la première fois que qu'aux
secousses se faire reprocher de
contourner les réseaux de distribution
officiel
on va en parler avec jacques nantel
professeur émérite à hec montréal
bonsoir monsieur nantel bonsoir même cet
homme alors c'est ça qu'on appelle le
marché gris comment ça fonctionne qu'est
ce que ça veut dire essentiellement
lemercier gris c'est lorsqu'un produit
se retrouvent je suis un détail un sens
que le manufacturier et de manière
explicite passé un accord pour vendre
son produit chez ce détaillant
contrairement au marché noir où ce sont
des contrefaçons on parle des sites du
véritable de produits sains c'est le bon
produit fabriqué par le bond
manufacturier qui se retrouve chez un
détaillant qui normalement n'auraient
pas le droit de le vendre
donc contrairement au marché noir le
marché gris c'est légal c'est ce qu'on
comprend oui c'est légal mais c'est
terriblement complexe parce que voyez
vous il ya plusieurs raisons pour
lesquelles un produit d'humains signé
par le manufacturier se retrouve chez un
détaillant qui normalement ne devrait
pas le vendre
la première de ces raisons et ça il faut
le mentionner
ça peut être le même facture il humain
qui est fautif c'est à dire que dans
certains cas le manufacturier va en
quelque sorte qu'on tournait son propre
réseau distribution donné l'exclusivité
de son produit à un détaillant se
retourne et de barres changer un petit
peu le produit alors on le voit beaucoup
dans les produits électroniques
notamment mettre un numéro de produit
différent et puis vendre sensiblement le
même produit chez un autre détaillant il
a évidemment le premier détail à bhl est
pas particulièrement contente c'est près
de settat de fait la deuxième façon de
voir émerger un marché gris c'est
lorsque le manufacturier passe par
distributeurs et c'est un de ses
distributeurs la kirwe un produit un
détaillant qui n'ont approuvé
on voit beaucoup à l'international par
exemple c'est ce qui était redouté dans
l'article ce matin lorsque le
manufacturier coty passe par différents
distributeurs souvent un par pays mais
ça peut être distributeurs américains
qui décident de de court circuiter le
distributeur canadien et de vendre dans
ce que si par exemple chez koch donc
c'est pour ça que l'entreprise elle-même
ne savait pas que ses produits étaient
en vente chez un grand détaillant bien
connu c'est quand même la difficulté à
s'imaginer que ça puisse arriver
oui ça peut être mal à imaginer dans
certains cas ça peut être 10 et damien
et imaginé pour de bonnes raisons parce
que c'est inimaginable
dans d'autres cas mais c'est
essentiellement une perte de son réseau
de distribution qui est en train ou un
effilochage de son réseau de
distribution qui est en train de revenir
on contrôle mal son réseau de
distribution
voyez-vous dans certains cas le
magnifique tuerie je dis pas que c'est
le cas ici
le manufacturier peut être sans doute
content que son produit se retrouve à
plus d'un endroit dans d'autres c'est
pas ça c'est un de ses distributeurs
dans un autre pays qui décident de faire
un peu d'huile et de commencer à s'en
aller lui-même à l'international est ce
que certaines de ces manipulations qui
bon ça ne viole pas la loi mais ce que
ça contourne l'esprit de la loi ou à
tout le moins des ententes commerciales
qui peuvent être passés par ses
distributeurs ou les manufacturiers pas
c'est une bonne question ça qu'on tourne
inévitablement les ententes qui ont lieu
maintenant comme c'est souvent à
l'international que le problème se pose
ça devient extrêmement difficile à mener
en cours par exemple si si une
entreprise vend son distributeur au
canada qui vend l'exclusivité dans un
magasin x ou y et que au même moment un
autre distributeur de notre pays décide
de vendre à un autre détaillant
toujours au canada la poursuite elle
doit se faire contre le distributeur
dans un autre pays ça devient
extrêmement compliqué ce qui est
malheureux là dedans évidemment c'est
que le magnifique tuerie qui fonctionne
avec plusieurs distributeurs ben perd un
peu la face dans cette histoire est
celle qu on parle ici de parfum mais
est-ce qu'il ya certains types de
produits qui sont plus enclins à faire
partie du marché gris oui en fait les je
vous dirais que là où l'on retrouve le
plus de marché gris c'est souvent dans
les produits pharmaceutiques ou certains
médicaments d'ordonnancé très souvent
tension tht dans un autre pays et corps
circuite les réseaux de distribution on
les retrouve dans les produits de luxe
parfois être par exemple également la
bijouterie et on le retrouve beaucoup
également dans les produits
électroniques le secteur auto le lait
produit du cannabis ça fait partie des
exemples aussi beaucoup moins enfin le
produit du cannabis sans doute la partie
légale chose mais la partie légale
beaucoup moins parce que le marché
canadien quand même pas ce gravier
pourvus dans le domaine de l'automobile
on le voit mais beaucoup moins parce que
ce sont des produits qui sont quand même
somme toute relativement facile à suivre
et c'est très rare que les que les
manufacturiers vont passer par des
distributeurs ou des distributeurs
locaux par quel type à ce qu'est ce
qu'on doit réglementer en fait si on
devait le faire par quel type de
réglementation pourraient se prémunir de
cette pratique là monsieur l'antenne
c'est le même que si on sait très
difficile de se prémunir par
réglementation en fait je vous dirais
que là où on doit être particulièrement
vigilant comme détaillant j'entends
c'est de s'assurer que son distributeur
est un distributeur qui contrôle bien
son réseau de distribution et que
il a la confiance de son magnifique
tuerie autrement dit plus vous êtes à
l'intérieur d'un réseau de distribution
qui est solide
- vous allez avoir de problème on voit
ce genre de problème là lorsque par
exemple les parts de marché de
manufacturiers commence à diminuer et
leurs souvent semaine facturier la
baisse de de gagner des parts de marché
en félicitant de nouveaux détails un
phénomène très intéressant merci de
l'avoir expliqué pour nous monsieur
nantel le plaisir